تووت تووت تووت تووت تووت توت توت توت
تووت تووت عدت من العطلة
تووت تووت آخذكم رحلة
تووت تووت لنشاهد فيها
تووت تووت ضيعا وبيووت
تووت تووت تووت توووت تووت توووت تووت
تووت تووت تووت توووت تووت
تلك الغيطان بكل مكان زرعت بالجهد من الإنسان
كي نأكل منها تووت تووت
نعما نشكرها تووت تووت
لا ننكر جهدا لمن يزرعها قمحا وشعيرا نخلا او تووت
تووت تووت تووت تووت تووت توت توت توت
نعمل بالتعب وبالإتقان كي تنهض بالجهد الأوطان
من يطلب علما توووت توووت
من يزرع حقلا توووت توووت
من يبني مدنا أو يبني عقلا أو يشدو لحنا عذب الصوت
تووت تووت تووت توووت تووت توووت تووت
أعود الآن بكم للدار فلنحمل للأهل الأزهار
لا تنسوا أبدا تووت تووت أني أحملكم تووت توووت
انا القاطرة لكي أوصلكم بأمان عند التوقيت
توووت تووت تووت توت توت توت توت